Là, je réfléchis à ça là. Puis on vit
dans une époque où que tout est
possible.
Littéralement, tu peux apprendre toutes
les skills que tu veux, n'importe quand.
Tout est accès à tout. même pas besoin
de payer sur YouTube, tuas tout
tu as accès à toutes les outils
nécessaires. Sincèrement, avec Claud
code en ce moment, tu peux tout faire
puis ça va juste continuer de grandir.
Donc tu apprends tout, tu es cap de de
tout apprendre, tu es capable de tout
faire parce que tu as des outils qui te
permettent de tout faire. Puis en plus
de ça, ces outils là, ils peuvent te
montrer comment les utiliser.
Ils t'expliquent comment que toi tu peux
les les utiliser. fait, il suffit juste
de
d'apprendre à utiliser
Claud code,
de te développer une
curiosité
puis une discipline parce que c'est ce
qui va faire la grosse différence parce
qu'étant donné que en ce moment tout le
monde a accès à tout
puis il y a le monde qui s'ouvre à tout
le monde qui une possibilité juste avec
un ordi
Claud code avec un abonnement à euh même
avec lui à 25 pièces, tu es capable de
faire vraiment du gros stock avec. Fait
que un ordi 25 pièces puis
un téléphone, tu es cap de tout faire.
Donc le monde il s'ouvre à toi. Ça que
ça fait que il y a une euh il y a une
compétitivité qui va se créer parce que
il va avoir tout le monde qui va tout
faire dans ce que tu fais. fait que
c'est là l'importance
de te lancer puis d'être discipliné à
faire quelque chose même si tu es pas
bon au début de le faire mais de le
faire longtemps puis constamment puis
c'est là que tu vas devenir bon puis que
Lia va pas être elle va pas pouvoir te
remplacer parce que tu vas avoir appris
à l'utiliser avec le temps la
discipline.
Ouais fait que c'était ça c'est juste
pour vous comme
une prise de conscience de crime. On vit
dans une époque qui est formidable qu'on
a accès à tout qui a une ouverture sur
le monde qu'on peut briser les barrières
que même les plafonds de verre que à
l'époque le monde avait parce que avant
par exemple se lancer en business
c'était très compliqué je veux dire ça
pnait des risques. Tu étais immense.
Juste par exemple de faire un MVP
que tu lancer un MVP, je sais pas pour
moi pour
un début un premier sais les débuts des
sass par exemple ou peu importe les
débuts de d'internet ou même avant de
starter en business puis faire du la
construction ben fallait que ça prenne
un gros investissement de base parce que
tu devais
acheter du stock pour te permettre de
commencer à travailler.
puis de payer des gens, acheter des
bureaux, tout ça. Mais là, tu peux
commencer à créer de la valeur sans
rien.
Donc
faut juste le faire, le faire du mieux
que tu peux, le plus tôt possible puis
le plus longtemps possible de manière
disciplinée.
Puis le monde s'ouvre à toi.
Littéralement, le monde s'ouvre à toi.
C'était la réflexion du jour.